يستطيع هذا الرجل المشي من جديد بعد تعرضه
لحادث شل قدرته على الحركه من الصدر وحتى
اخمس القدمين وذلك بسبب قطع حبله الشوكي
تماما من المنتصف خطوات صغيره لكنها كانت
كافيه لتغيير حياه هذا الرجل ديريك فيدك
البالغ من العمر 38 عاما واعطت بصيصا من
الامل للكثيرين ممن فقدوا القدره على
المشي
والحركه ولعلاج الحاص في حبله الشوكي تم
استخدام الخلايا الجذعيه الماخوذه من
التجويف الانفي لديك وتم زرعها في المنطقه
المصابه من الحبل الشوكي ثم قام الاطباء
باستخدام عده شرائح من الانسجه العصبيه من
كاحله وتم وضعها بالحبل ايضا الفكره من
وراء ذلك ان اعصاب الكاحل والخلايا
الجذعيه للانف تعمل بمثابه جسر يسمح
للالياف العصبيه
بالنمو على عكس جميع الالياف العصبيه في
جسم هذه الالياف تنمو باستمرار طول حياه
الانسان كما انه اذا حصل قطع لها فنمو
مجددا فهي تصلح نفسها بنفسها على عكس
خلايا الحبل الشوكي الغير قادره على اصلاح
نفسها في حال اي تلف وبعد سته شهور من
العمليه الجراحيه التي خضع لها ديرك كان
باستطاعته فعل هذا وبعد اربع سنوات كان
باستطاعته عمل اكثر من هذا
بكثير انه يستطيع المشي الان بمساعده جهاز
للمشي يستطيع قياده سيارته يمكنه ممارسه
هوايته المفضله وهي الصيد مع اصدقائه ها
هي حياته تعود له شيئا فشيئا ديريك استعمل
التعبير التالي اشعر بانني ولدت من جديد
وهذا شيء رائع بالنسبه الي انه انجاز ضخم